the left sort of critical hollywood
establishment
is furious about this movie but the
audience seemed to really like it so
thanks everyone for coming out
hanging out with us i guess that might
have been the last time
we were all hanging out together because
i took a couple of days off you know i
am
genuinely very very sad that president
trump is leaving office
it's been so fun it has been the most
fun political
experience of my life that i've ever
lived through
uh conservatives i think have
accomplished more certainly than we've
accomplished in my life
and probably for many decades before
that
so i am genuinely very sad on
inauguration day
however i'm not that sad generally
because the reason i've been out the
past couple days is i just had a kid
i would say thank you to everybody for
sending in
the uh well wishes my
my son has now already mastered
expressions of bemused dismay
and droll self-satisfaction i posted
some of these photos over the weekend
that means that he now has mastered the
entire
uh breadth of conservative emotions
that's pretty much it that's pretty much
all you can get to so
we're all very excited about that it is
helping to temper
our sadness that president koffe is
leaving office which is a genuinely
sad thing we we can now say we have at
least one
new conservative american future
voter of for good things uh on
on this earth and in this country one
new conservative american
soon to be joined by i'm far from afraid
to say
11 million new overwhelmingly
left-wing americans so you see one thing
i was really happy about
with the birth of my son is that well
there are
obviously many many things i was very
happy about but not the least of which
was
he is not a biden baby you see he was
due
on the 18th for a first child it's it's
typical for the kid to come later than
the due date i thought no
biden becomes president on the 20th this
is going to be a biden baby he's going
to miss out on all the fun
but he got in on time so he got in two
days before the biden presidency
and uh we're very excited for that
all the more reason that i haven't slept
in a few days if i fall asleep at the
desk today
that's you know perfectly fine just have
someone come in and poke me
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
you